hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my mr. robot season 2 episode 1 and 2
videos basically like a two-part
premiere so just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the episode yet kind of
picking up in the ashes of what happened
with like that big hack basically
erasing all records of debt in the
United States those are the encrypted
records that are being held ransom but
the twist is is the evil Corp is still
just as powerful as it used to be so in
effect that you know what they're saying
is is that even though they were
successful they were kind of
unsuccessful like they didn't completely
bring down evil Corp because you have
the evil CEO going to the government
pushing them around for another bailout
you have Angela who is now working for
evil Corp you know sort of you know
pursuing the American dream she's like
I'm going to have everything that's
coming to me like she really loves
feeling powerful now that she's making a
lot of money she's really successful she
feels valued even though she's kind of
lying to herself but you can kind of see
that you know if she's successful at her
job it means that she's undoing a lot of
the damage that Elliott did so they're
kind of at odds of the season without
really knowing it but the biggest twist
do you find you like Elliott talks about
his program his routine you meet a new
friend who's probably imaginary who just
won't stop talking about Seinfeld that's
something I'll talk about in a second
but the big twist of the episode is that
he realizes that mr. robot is the one
that engineered the routine so that he
could use that period when Elliott was
asleep to actually control him so
whereas season one was mostly Elliott
coming to realize that he was mr. robot
like he didn't realize that in season
one so he just thought that mr. robot
was someone that was helping him out he
didn't know that it was his father he
talks about him like he's his special
friend now it's more and more like the
war between the two of them like mr.
robot is warring for control of his
conscious mind so even though they've
struck a balance like they had a balance
in this episode where he's like I'm not
gonna help you continue our work
together unless you tell me where
tyrella is like what you did with him
because they made you believe that he
killed him at the end of last season but
then we learned because of the music box
and the phone call at the end that he's
still alive that's who Elliott's talking
to on that red phone the Seinfeld
episode that Leon's talking about at the
beginning of the episode that you know
the one where they're all waiting to get
a table for the entire episode is kind
of a metaphor
for you know the plot of the first two
episodes the macro arc that's teeing up
the season starting again because you
know the first couple of episodes is all
about Elliott trying to stay away from
their workings like I don't want to do
this I've been hiding out this whole
time but then as Gideon gets murdered
there's this passage from the book of
revelations that the woman is speaking
at their supporter at the church support
group the l8 goes to and it's all like
the passage when you read the passage
it's all about God explaining that if
you take up my cause you'll receive all
these wonderful things so it's a call to
action given by God in Eliot slowly
falls asleep and then boom he's on the
phone so it's almost like saying he's
taking up the cause so he'll receive all
these awesome things because mr. robot
technically upheld the terms of their
agreement so it seems like conscious
Elliot like you know who is this you
know what the hell's going on and it's
Tyrells voice on the other side of the
line that because mr. robot gave Elliot
what he wanted they are going to work
together so you know he's gonna be
working with Craig Robinson it seems
like so just to oversimplify Elliot's
basically going to start hacking again I
don't know what his involvement with eff
society is going to be yet because
they're kind of like a separate entity
his sister's basically built out the
team they're working on sort of like the
larger social engineering plan that was
what the burning of the money was it was
you know meant to make this big
statement you know social engineering
get the people behind the bank to burn
the money and that's kind of what Angela
was talking about on the phone with
Bloomberg like they're gonna do a big
interview about it you have to let us
ask him about burning the money like why
the hell did he burn five million
dollars so there's all these running
plots you have like the F Society social
engineering plot you have Eliot versus
mr. robot you have evil Corp trying to
stay alive using government bailout
money and then you have what's going on
with Tyrell and then kind of on a funny
level you know always floating in the
periphery you know you have to wonder
how many times when Elliott's talking to
someone else he's imagining it in his
head so like Gideon sees his mother in
his house that's how you know that she's
real when you're seeing other characters
that Elliot typically sees from other
characters perspectives so like if
somebody else sees Craig Robinson's
character you know that Craig Robinson
is real so as for right now I think the
only fictional people inside Elliot's
mine are Leon the Seinfeld friend that
he eats three meals a day at the same
diner with
in mr. robot they're like the only two
fictional people in this mind right now
but I wouldn't be surprised if another
one pops up so here's my big question
for you guys like what is your favorite
thing from these first two episodes and
what do you think about Elliott's
fictional friend like do you actually
think that Leon is a creation of his
mind because Ellie just kind of sits
there and listens to him I think even
though the program as he calls it was a
creation of mr. robots you know which is
bit like Elliott created mr. robot mr.
robot created the program mr. robot is
trying to take over Elliott's mind so
maybe mr. robot created Leon but really
it's Elliott that's creating all this
inside his might just like his fractured
subconscious and they actually like I
love the way they panned up on the image
of his brain scan as a child his mind is
kind of the engine for a lot of this
narrative but the flashback does give
you a good sense for how he slowly broke
down like his mind started to fracture
is a way to deal with all the shittiness
in his life so like I said do not be
surprised if we get more flashbacks if
we see more fictional characters inside
Elliott's mind I'm really interested in
Craig Robinson's character because you
know the dog like the way he talks about
the dog seeming like such a nice
unassuming person seems like he might
wind up being pretty terrifying but the
episodes were great they were really
just meant to kind of carry forward the
plot from last season like the
consequences of that oh and I almost
forgot to mention grace Gummer's
character she works for the FBI she's
going to be pursuing eff society like
the people that perpetrated the hack so
she is a good character but she'll be
gunning for Elliott and his friends when
she starts to figure out who's really
behind the hack so the new big
characters this season are Craig
Robinson's character who Eliot's going
to be working with you have grace comer
and then you have like the government
like the government itself is a much
larger character because you have evil
Corp pursuing more bailout money then
you have the FBI pursuing eff Society
so what's probably gonna happen is is I
don't I don't think I'm gonna be doing
weekly videos every single week but I
will probably check back in at the end
of the season this is gonna be a really
fun series I think there's supposed to
be 12 episodes total so it's not like a
huge time commitment it's a Wednesday
night show on USA Network if you don't
get the channel that it airs on they do
post episodes digitally on their website
at USA Network com like the day after
the new game of thrones coming later
tonight the actors who plays Lyanna
stark was saying some funny things about
her
joycie like you know baby john's snow
scene so be sure to subscribe to get
that
and then tomorrow there's gonna be a
whole bunch of new Star Wars stuff Star
Wars Celebration is happening in Europe
right now they're dropping a new rogue
one trailer so I'll do a video for that
and then there's gonna be some Star Wars
Episode 8 stuff happening - they just
wrapped filming like principal
photography there's still a whole lot of
work to do they haven't started
post-production yet they'll have pickups
later like they'll bring the actors back
next year to do research just like every
movie does but for the most part they've
done the bulk of the filming that
they're going to do with the actors so
Game of Thrones tonight then a whole
bunch of Star Wars tomorrow what you
guys wait for my next video to post you
can click here for my Harley Quinn
therapy trailer for Suicide Squad and
you can click here for my black flash
like who is the new black flash on the
flash season 3 video thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you